STUDENT: --two by Mary
MARY WOOTTERS: OK.
We'll wait for folks
to finish filing in.
While we wait for folks
to finish filing in,
consider submitting
a speed talk.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
MARY WOOTTERS: OK.
So now we are all back
for Talk 2, which--
so recall the outline was
Talk 1, this basic paradigm,
which now we've seen--
OK, not quite fair
to say we've seen it
three times because the
last one was (NOISE),
but we've seen it at
least 2 and 1/2 times.
So hopefully, we're
on board with that.
And Talk 2 is about
what we can do
on top of that basic paradigm.
What are various techniques that
we can use to make that better.
So quick recap,
because I know it's
been a long 20
minutes or whatever.
When we last left our
heroes, algebraic codes,
what was going on?
So we saw two problems.
We saw the unique decoding
problem and the list decoding
problem.
So the unique decoding
problem, our goal
was to handle a number
of errors which was less
than half the distance over--
with less than
half the distance.
And for Reed-Solomon
codes, the distance--
sorry, that should be times N.
The distance is 1 minus R times
N about, and so we wanted
T to be about this times
N. Sorry for the typo.
And if that's the case, then we
know when we see this received
word that there's a unique
code word we can decode to
and we want to do
that efficiently.
We also looked at the
list decoding problem
where we were allowed to
take T a little bit bigger.
Again, there's an
N missing there.
We want T to be 1
minus R times N. Sorry.
And the goal is to recover
all of the code words
in that ball and implicit in
that statement is that if we
want to do that efficiently,
that there ought not be too
many code words in that ball.
That's what we're hoping for.
And we saw an
algorithmic paradigm
to do this, which
had three steps.
One, interpolate some
polynomial-- two,
assert that that polynomial
explains our target function F.
And three, use that
explanation to solve for F,
or solve for some small
positive list of possibilities.
OK.
So this is what
we did last time.
We saw this-- saw
several examples
of this for both unique
decoding list decoding.
And what we're going to do this
time for the next hour or so,
is see how we can
improve on this.
There's still more to do.
Can we make these
algorithms faster?
People were asking
about the complexity,
and I was, like,
yeah, polynomial time,
do linear algebra, or whatever.
We'll see how we can make
this faster near linear time.
That's going to be our goal for
the second half of the talk.
Can we get smaller
list sizes, and can we
work over smaller fields?
So last time we
were always working
over these big, big fields.
But like often, we really
want to be working over F2.
How can we do that?
So today we're going
to-- or in this talk,
we're going to answer
those questions.
So techniques to
improve this paradigm.
So here's going to be
a list of techniques.
And along the way, we'll
see where they stop working
and what the open questions are.
So the first technique
I'm going to talk about
is locality, or
leveraging locality.
So how can we
speed up algorithms
by running them on smaller bits?
This is going to be
real fast because we
have a whole two
hours of locality
later, or more, by Elena.
So this will just be a teaser.
The second technique
I'm going to talk about
is distance amplification.
So basically, one of the punch
lines of technique one is
it's--
we can make faster
algorithms, but at the cost
of getting worse parameters.
And so then we'll
see some techniques
for getting the parameters
back in line after we do that.
The third technique
I'll want to talk about
is alphabet reduction.
We'll see two different
ways to do this.
One, code concatenation,
and the second I'll
just mention very briefly
using algebraic geometry codes.
And if time, I have
a fourth technique
to talk about, which is
how to exploit structure
in the codes and the algorithms.
But I'm not sure if
we'll get to that.
But if we do, then it's there.
And if we don't,
then that's fine.
So we'll talk about all of
these different techniques.
And, yeah, along the way
highlight several open problems
and what's still
left to do here.
And as usual, as with
last time, please
do interrupt me
and ask questions.
So I anticipate I won't be
able to get to technique four,
even if I don't get to some of
these techniques, that's fine.
I want to make sure
people understand.
Cool.
OK.
So let's get started
with locality.
And as I mentioned before,
we have a whole talk series
on locality later in
the workshop by Elena.
Where's Elena?
Elena, yay.
So this is just a teaser.
So the idea of
locality, at least
in the context of algorithms
for algebraic codes
is, we want to somehow
either make a big code out
of little codes, or view a code
that we already have as being
made out of littler codes.
So let me see, I'm
just going to describe
this with a couple
of examples, rather
than a formal definition since
this is a hand-wavy thing.
So one example of
this is tensor codes.
So suppose we
start with the code
C, subset of sigma to the
N. We can define C tensor C.
So this is going to be a code
with longer block length.
It'll have block length
N squared instead of N
over the same alphabet.
We're going to
define it as follows.
So it's going to
be the set of all N
by N matrices A, such that all
of the rows of A lie in my base
code, and all of the columns
of A lie in my base code.
So if I look at
any row or column,
I get something
in the base code.
And more generally,
you can define
C tensor C tensor dot to dot
tensor C in the natural way.
So you take an M dimensional
tensor, and every--
this one and that one, and
that one, and whatever,
need to live in the code.
This make sense?
And this is some way of
making a big code where
it has lots of little codes in
it, because I have this code
word in my big code.
And then there's all
these little code
words from the little
code floating around.
Another place where we see
this is in multivariate codes.
For example, I'll
just draw a picture
of bivariate Reed-Muller codes.
So a bivariate
Reed-Muller code, this
is like the bivariate analog
of the Reed-Solomon code
that we saw last time.
So the code words
are, again, I'm
going to think of them as
matrices where the rows are
indexed by field elements beta.
The columns are indexed
by field melons alpha.
And what goes in
the alpha beta place
is F of alpha beta for some
low degree polynomial F.
So this is the Reed-Muller code,
the bivariate Reed-Muller code
of dimension, or of
degree at most K--
or of degree K minus 1.
And this has this same
notion of locality
in that we can find lots
of little Reed-Solomon code
words floating around here.
So if I take any
line in S squared,
so I have this space F squared,
and I look at any line here.
And I look at the
restriction of this code word
to that line, what
I'm going to get
is a univariate
polynomial, right?
So basically, just a
Reed-Solomon code word.
So any line that I take in
this square, the picture
isn't quite right
because it doesn't
look like a field structure.
But you imagine it wraps
around, or something.
And any line that I
take in this square
looks like a
Reed-Solomon code word.
So I have all these
little code words
from some other code
embedded in my big code.
Another example is lifted codes.
So I could imagine
instead of this definition
here where I say, OK, I'm
going to define it like this.
And, oh, hey, it just
happens to have this property
that when I restrict
to a line I get
something in my original code.
I can actually just define the
code that way to begin with.
I could define it
to be evaluations
of all of the
bivariate polynomials
F, all of my
bivariate functions F
so that when I
restrict to a line,
I get something in
the code, right.
This turns out to be different.
This is called a lifted code.
And you might think that if C is
a Reed-Solomon code, that these
are actually the same
that the Reed-Muller code
words are all the things
that restrict to lines.
In some parameter
regimes, that's true.
It's actually not true,
in general, in fact.
And I think, Elena,
are you going
to talk about that,
lifting codes?
Maybe, a little bit?
OK.
So stick around for Elena's
talk to see more about that,
or ask me later.
This is a cool phenomenon that
is not related to this talk.
So I'm going to skip by
it, but it's a fun fact.
Anyway, so these are
three different examples
of ways that natural codes
we can come up with that
have little codes embedded
in some bigger code.
And the point for algorithms is
that if we have a big code made
out of little codes,
well, this gives us
some algorithmic leverage.
Because then we can run our
decoder on these little code
words and patch them
together somehow.
And the hope is that,
well, because the code
words are little,
then this is going
to run very quickly, right?
Even if I have an
algorithm for my base code
that takes time, like,
N squared, or something,
if the whole block length is N
squared, then all of a sudden
that's linear time, not
quadratic time, like, yay.
So that's the hope.
Of course, there are lots of
subtleties with this hope,
like, OK, how do we
patch things together,
and which little code words
do we choose to run on?
There are tons of
little code words.
If we do it on all of them,
that's going to be too slow,
and lots of things like that.
And then the thing
I actually want
to talk about here is
that the parameters are
going to get worse.
So these first two things
I'll just sweep under the rug
and say, for all of
these different examples,
there are ways to deal with it.
But I want to just mention
what happens to the parameters.
So, for example,
for tensor codes,
actually, I feel like I've
just been barreling on.
Are there questions?
I haven't said
anything super precise,
but basic paradigm make sense?
Cool.
OK.
So, yeah.
So we need to figure out how
to patch things together.
You need to figure out which
of these little code words
you want to leverage.
How you do that is a
case-by-case basis.
But inevitably, the
parameters are going
to get a little bit worse.
So for example,
for tensor codes,
let's say that
your base code C--
say it has really high rate,
and reasonably small distance.
So let's say rate 1 minus
epsilon and distance epsilon.
So we saw last time
this-- this is optimal.
This meets the Singleton
bound, like, hurrah, we
have this optimal base code C.
Let's consider C
tensor C. It turns out
that to get the
parameters for T tensor C,
you basically just square the
distance and square the rate.
So squaring the rate,
that's still a high rate
code, like, 1 minus epsilon
squared is to first order
1 minus 2 epsilon
is still close to 1.
But the distance is now--
or the relative distance
is now epsilon squared.
But we wanted it to
be like 2 epsilon.
So that's not good.
So that this is not optimal.
So whenever we do
this, we're moving away
from this optimal
parameter we want to be in.
And so that's going to
motivate the next technique
that we're going to use.
I'm not going to talk
anymore about locality
because that's, again, just
a teaser for Elena's talk.
But the next thing
I want to talk about
is distance amplification.
I will go into a little
bit more detail about this.
And the idea here is,
OK, let's say we've
done this local thing somehow.
But now, we have a code
that has a fast algorithm
but bad parameters.
How do we get the
parameters back in line?
And distance amplification
is a technique to do that.
So, yeah.
So the basic idea is
we'd like to transform
a code we have into one
with better parameters,
ideally, in a way
that respects--
that plays nice with
algorithms that we
might have for that code.
And so today what I'm
going to talk about
is a particular technique known
as AEL distance amplification.
So AEL here stands for
Alon, Edmonds, and Luby
after this paper from 1995.
And this technique has been
used frequently since then
in the algorithms for
algebraic codes literature.
I'll mention just one paper,
this paper by Kopparty, Meir,
Ron-Zewi, and Saraf
from 2015 just because I
think this is the first paper
where I really appreciate
the power of this technique.
But it's been used--
it's in this algorithmic context
in a lot of other places.
I should mention,
also, there are
lots of other versions of
distance amplification.
So, for example, you might
be familiar with this sort
of classic ABNNR.
Distance amplification is also
a more recent version also
with range amplification
by Cohen and Yankovitz,
and many others.
But today just to
focus on one thing,
I'm going to look
at AEL distance.
So here's how this works.
So we're going to have two
ingredients that we start with.
The first is our base code.
So we need a high
rate code C, and we'll
think of C as having a
fast decoding algorithm.
But maybe it can't
handle very much error.
So imagine this is
something we get after doing
this locality thing.
So we have a code C,
it's very high rate,
like, maybe we've tensored it up
so it still has very high rate,
but it has teeny tiny distance.
We have super fast
algorithms for it,
but it can only handle a little
bit of error corresponding
to that teeny tiny distance.
And we want to make
it handle more error.
So that's ingredient number one.
Ingredient number two is a
balanced bipartite expander
graph.
So it'll look like this.
So it's-- what is this?
It's a bipartite
graph, and it has
the following nice
pseudorandomness property
where if I look at any
set S on the right,
small enough set S on
the right, like this one.
And I look at the
vertices on the left
and I ask, how much do these
vertices touch that set?
Most vertices on the left should
touch that set about as much
as you would expect.
So for example
here, if I highlight
all of the edges coming
out of this set, OK,
this set has size M
over 3 in this example.
So I should expect a
third of everyone's--
like a third of this vertices
edges to touch the set.
And indeed, that's the
case for this vertex
that has three edges
coming out, and one
of them touches the set.
And that's true for
most of these vertices.
But it's not true for this one.
This one has two.
So it's OK if there's a few
that have too many edges.
But most of them should
have about what you expect.
I'm not going to be any
more precise about this.
Like I said, the first talk
was the one where I actually
did a little bit of math.
This talk, very
hand-wavy high level.
You can ask me
for details later.
OK.
So this is what I mean by
balanced bipartite expander
graph.
So what is this distance
amplification technique?
So say we have these
two ingredients.
We have our base code C, and
we have our expander graph.
What are we going to do?
So I'm going to start
with the code word from C,
and what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to show you how to
transform that into a code
word from some
new code that I'll
define by this transformation.
So the first thing
I'm going to do to C
is, I'm going to chop it up.
So I'm going to chop it up into
chunks of some particular size.
And then I'm going to take
each one of those chunks
and encode them with a little
tiny Reed-Solomon code,
or maybe a folded Reed-Solomon
code, or a code of my choice
that has the
properties that I want.
And basically, the
idea is I'm going
to end up with a
final code that mimics
the properties of this little
code, but like in a big scale
and with linear time algorithms.
So I'll encode each chunk with
a little Reed-Solomon code.
And now, it is expander time.
Yay.
There's less enthusiasm.
Now, it's expander time.
Yay.
All right, there we go, good.
So now it's expander time.
And so what we're
going to do is,
we're going to take
our bipartite expander
and we're going to
use it to shuffle up
the coordinates here, like,
shuffle up the symbols.
So what is that
going to look like?
I'm going to instantiate
a new code word over here.
This is going to be
our final code word.
And I'm going to populate it
with the symbols from this code
word, but sort of munged up
according to the expander.
So what does that look like?
So let's suppose that this
first symbol here-- oh,
and I should say the
vertices of the expander
correspond to chunks
in this vector here.
So this first chunk, let's say
it has three symbols in it,
it corresponds to this vertex.
And the number of
symbols in this chunk
should be the same as the
degree of the vertex, which
fortunately, it is
in my little example.
And now, what I'm
going to do is,
I'm basically just going
to shift these symbols
across the expander.
So this alpha, that's
the first symbol,
so I'll send it across
the first edge over there.
The beta is the
second symbol, so I'll
send it across the second edge.
And gamma is the
third symbol, so I'll
send it across the
third edge like that.
Does that make sense?
And then I'm going
to do this for all
of the different symbols.
I'm not going to do that
many PowerPoint animations,
but you can see
where that's going.
So, for example, down here if
I had alpha prime, beta prime,
gamma prime, those would
end up in the symbols that
were connected to this vertex.
Does this process make sense?
It's very obnoxious
to write down formally
but, hopefully, a picture is OK.
OK.
And so then once we do
this, this green thing here
on the right, this is going
to be our new code word.
And here, just like with
folded Reed-Solomon codes
that we saw last
time, we're going
to take our alphabet
to be larger
than our original alphabet.
So our alphabet symbols are
now these folded symbols.
They're symbols--
they're vector-valued.
So our alphabet is
going to be F to the S
where S is whatever the length
of these little chunks are.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So now, I have a code
which I define by--
for every code word
in C, do this process,
get this code word.
And my new code is all
of these new code words.
Why have we done this?
Let's see what
happens when we want
to say correct some errors.
And hopefully, I'll describe
the decoding algorithm
and that will
explain why we wanted
to do this in the first place.
And then we'll kind of wave
my hands about analyzing it.
OK.
So suppose that there
are some errors.
And remember, my symbols here
are these big mega symbols.
That means errors
are going to occur
at the level of mega
symbols like that.
OK.
There are some errors like that.
And let's see what the
decoding algorithm does.
So the first thing we're going
to do, at least as a thought
experiment, is--
let's imagine
propagating these errors
backwards to where
they came from.
So we're going to propagate them
back across the expander graph.
And so there were
six little symbols
in error here--
two mega symbols.
And we have these six little
symbols in error here.
But now, they're all spread
out over all the mega symbols.
And the property of
this bipartite expander
was that for any set that
looks like this, most
of the vertices over here
touch it in about the number
you'd expect.
And so what that means is that
most of the chunks over here
have about the expected
number of errors.
So what we've
basically done here
with the pseudorandomness
of this expander graph
is turned worst case errors into
something like random errors.
Each chunk has about
what we'd expect,
or most chunks have
about what we'd expect.
And that's great,
because if we, let's say,
design this little
Reed-Solomon code here
to handle the amount of
errors that we expect,
that that means that most
chunks we can actually correctly
decode.
So let's try to decode those
little Reed-Solomon codes.
And almost all of them
will turn out well.
Of course, there might
be a few vertices,
like this one, that touch
the bad set too much
and they have too many
errors, and that one's
going to be wrong.
But it's not too many of them.
So now, we're back here.
We have that most of the symbols
are correct except for this one
maybe.
So our next step is we're
going to just unchop things up.
So again, we get
most symbols that
are correct except for
a few that are wrong.
But now, we can use the
properties of C, right?
Remember C, capital
C, was a code
that had a really fast
decoding algorithm,
but it couldn't handle
very many errors.
But now, look, we
have way fewer errors
now than we had to begin with
so we can run C's algorithm.
And that works.
And then we can correct
the whole thing.
So that's the basic idea.
Does this make sense?
Who has questions?
OK.
So let me wave my hands
about parameters real quick.
What is the rate of this
code and how many errors
can it handle, let's say, if
we wanted a unique decoding?
OK.
Well, C had high rate.
This step of chopping things up
doesn't change the rate at all,
it just repackages stuff.
This step does change the rate.
And, basically,
the rate of this,
the amount that the rate
blows up in this step
is, basically,
just by multiplying
by the rate of whatever the
inner Reed-Solomon code was.
This step doesn't
change the rate at all
because, again, it's just
scrambling things up.
So the rate of the
whole thing is the rate
of the original
code times the rate
of whatever this little
Reed-Solomon code is.
If the rate of the original
code is close to 1,
then the rate of
this whole thing
is close to the rate of whatever
the original Reed-Solomon code
was.
And how many errors
can it correct?
Well, the error
correction was really
based on what could the
little inner Reed-Solomon code
do with the expected
number of errors.
So it can correct, basically,
the fraction of errors
that the original
Reed-Solomon code could.
So that's great.
We've inherited this
optimal trade-off
between rate and distance
from the Reed-Solomon code.
But now, we actually
have a much longer code.
How long does all
this algorithm take?
What's the complexity
of this algorithm?
OK.
Munging up symbols can be done
in, basically, linear time.
Decoding, right, maybe
this is slow relative
to these little block lengths.
But these are really short.
So overall, this is also really
fast, basically, linear time.
And then unchopping
and correcting,
right, the whole
point was that C
had this really fast, maybe near
linear time decoding algorithm.
So altogether, this
whole decoding process
can be near linear
time, but we've
inherited those optimal
combinatorial properties
from the inner
Reed-Solomon tree.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
STUDENT: If we use the
folded Reed-Solomon code,
what changes?
PROFESSOR: Great, yeah.
So what changes if we use
a folded Reed-Solomon code?
So for unique
decoding, not too much,
but this is a perfect
segue into my next slide.
What if we want to do
list decoding, or-- yeah.
STUDENT: A question about the--
in the last column,
you say, OK, I'm
going to attack this
block of three letters
as my larger letter.
But I'm just curious why is
that my error model versus
an adversarial error who just
picks every small letter?
PROFESSOR: Great, yeah.
So the question is,
why is this allowed?
Why can I just say I decide the
alphabet size is Q to the S?
Yeah.
So it depends on the
application and the error model
that you have in mind.
So you're absolutely right that
in a lot of different settings,
the natural error
model acts on bits,
and this is just not
right for those settings.
We will see next, I think,
how to actually leverage
this for those settings.
But there's another step
that needs to be done.
However, there are settings
where it makes sense to say,
oh, the natural unit of
errors is a large alphabet.
So for example, in distributed
storage, or something,
you might say, what's
the failure mode?
That whole server
goes down, right?
And in that model, a
larger alphabet size
naturally makes sense.
STUDENT: That's perfect, thanks.
STUDENT: In practice, do I just
pick a fixed bipartite balanced
graph of every size, or is
there some notion of matching
the graph to the problem?
PROFESSOR: Great, yeah.
So the question is, how
do I pick the graph?
Yeah, so-- yeah.
So I do need to match this graph
to the problem that I have.
In particular, what do I need?
I need the number of
vertices to be the same
as the number of chunks.
And I need the
degree of the graph
to be the size of the chunks.
And-- yeah.
Typically, I'm not going to
work through the parameters
because it's a mess.
But typically, the number
of chunks is order N,
and the size of the
chunks is order 1.
And you-- there exist explicit
constructions of expander
graphs that for many
such parameter regimes.
I think it is a fair
critique that you often
have to take N
fairly large to find
good constructions of these.
So, yeah, there's
some happy out there.
More questions?
It's really good.
Yeah.
STUDENT: In a practical
application, could you--
to get around the
alphabet size thing, could
you randomize the
choice of expander graph
and send that
beforehand and then--
so that you get around--
the adversary is not
able to know which--
where to concentrate its
errors to screw you up, or does
the question make sense?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think the question is--
there's two things there.
One, can I just
pick a random graph?
And the answer is
that we'll have
this combinatorial property
with high probability.
So even for a worst
case adversary,
that will be fine,
with high probability.
But then, also, can
I do something random
for the adversary goes.
STUDENT: Like the alphabet's--
the large alphabet size is
putting a restriction on the
adversary that it can only
corrupt within a
block at a time.
Could you get
around that somehow
by randomizing the
choice of the graph
so that it doesn't know
where to concentrate
its errors to screw you up on
the other side of the graph?
PROFESSOR: I see.
Yeah.
Maybe we can talk more about
that particular suggestion
offline.
But in a moment, I
will talk about--
yeah, I have a whole
chunk coming up
on how do we turn this
stuff for big alphabets
into stuff over small
alphabets, and there
will be some randomness
involved there,
and maybe that's close to
what you're alluding to.
So maybe hold that thought
for just a little bit.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Is this still-- is
this transformation going
to maintain the linear--
the linearity of the code?
I feel very confused when
I see these blocks being
broken up and then--
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah.
So the question is,
does this maintain
the linearity of the code?
Sort of.
So if my original
code, let's say,
has these little teeny symbols
that live over some field F,
and this original
code is F linear,
then this final
thing is still going
to be F linear because
shuffled things up.
But permutations are linear.
STUDENT: Right, sure.
PROFESSOR: If your
original code--
I guess it could
make sense to think
about this is your original
code and maybe these blocks were
linear over some extension
field, or something,
that that will be destroyed.
But, yeah, linearity over the
small field will be maintained.
Was there another question?
That was your question.
Cool.
OK.
So maybe in the interest of
time, let me move forward.
Hopefully, everyone gets
the basic mechanism here.
But I want to go back to Henry's
question, which was right--
here was Reed-Solomon codes.
I have this little asterisk.
We could use folded
Reed-Solomon codes.
What would that get us?
Well, what we saw the--
or what we very
quickly waved our hands
at at the end of
the previous talk
is that folded Reed-Solomon
codes can do list decoding
better than Reed-Solomon codes.
So this whole picture was for--
list was for unique decoding.
What if I want to
do list decoding?
What if there's too much error?
Then these little Reed-Solomon
codes wouldn't know what to do.
But if I had a folded
Reed-Solomon code,
I would know what to do.
And so this is a
good opportunity
for a quick aside
on list recovery.
Yeah.
So the previous cartoon showed
how to do unique decoding.
What about list decoding?
So let's go back
to this cartoon.
We're halfway through.
And let's say we want
to do list decoding now.
So the rate of the inner
code, which should now
be a folded
Reed-Solomon code here,
is too high to handle this
amount of error, right?
So let's say it's a
folded Reed-Solomon code.
So maybe I can list a code
instead of uniquely decoding.
And what that's
going to give me is
a short list of possibilities
for each one of these chunks.
And most of them are
going to be correct,
meaning, that the right answer
is contained in those lists.
And some of them might be wrong
if there are too many errors
that ended up in that thing.
And now, we have the problem of,
from this situation going back
to the original code word
C, how do we do that.
Right.
So the problem here
is, we somehow--
we want to go from these input
lists, this A, B, C, D, E, F,
F0, Y, Z back to C, or to a
short list of possible C's.
So we want to generate a
list of all possible C's
that agree with these lists.
And this problem is
known as list recovery.
So here's an informal
definition of list recovery.
We say that C is
list-recoverable
if given short input
lists, one for each symbol,
you can efficiently find
all of the code words in C,
and implicitly this means that
there are not too many of them,
so that CI lives in
SI for lots of Is.
So that's exactly the
problem that we just saw.
And this problem has a name,
it's called list-recovery.
Fun exercise-- folded
Reed-Solomon codes actually
are efficiently
list-recoverable, as well
as list-decodable.
I'm not going to work it
out but, hint, we already
saw the algorithm.
So if you haven't seen this
before, do it on your own.
The same Guruswamy-Lang
algorithm will also work.
OK.
So what that means for
distance amplification
is, let's say if we take our
little inner codes to be folded
Reed-Solomon codes, and we
take that outer code word--
outer code C to be some
list-recoverable code
with fast algorithms,
which we'll
say how to get in a moment,
then if you have a high rate
code that can handle
a little bit of error,
then you can transform it
into a rate R code that
can handle the optimal amount
of error rate R for any R
that you choose.
And that's what this
AEL actually gets you.
So it's a very neat technique.
Cool.
Are there questions about
this before I move on to--
STUDENT: Oh, so in the
definition of list-recovery,
this S1, S2, et cetera, they
can be overlaps between them?
Because the way you have showed
us, there were no overlaps.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah,
that's right, yeah.
These S1, S2, they can have
overlaps between them, yeah.
I guess I showed A,
B, C, D, whatever,
just because I didn't
want to do subscripts.
Yeah, that's right.
More questions?
Cool.
OK.
So where are we?
So far, we've said--
all right.
Technique one,
locality, let's come up
with a code that has
real fast algorithms
but real bad parameters.
All right.
Distance amplification,
let's transform this code
to get the parameters
back in line.
But as several of
you just pointed out,
like, hey, that makes the
alphabet size real big.
Why is that allowed?
Sometimes that's allowed, but
sometimes that's not ideal.
So our next technique is
going to be two different ways
to reduce the alphabet size.
And we're going to start with
code concatenation, which is
the most natural thing to do.
So alphabet reduction-- right.
So so far, all the codes
we've been talking about
have big alphabets.
Reed-Solomon codes
need big alphabets
because they need the field
size to be at least a number
of valuation points.
Folded Reed-Solomon codes
have alphabet size even bigger
because we did the folding, AEL.
This distance
amplification we just saw
might make the alphabet
size yet bigger still.
Again, this is fine
for some applications,
but ideally, we'd want binary
codes for many applications.
I just want to
take a quick aside
to mention that
this is a challenge.
So lots and lots of big
open problems whenever
binary codes are involved.
So here are some
natural questions
you might want to ask
about binary codes.
What is the best trade-off
between rate and distance
possible for binary codes?
Open, right, this is one of
the biggest open questions
in coding theory.
How about the best trade-off
that we know to exist?
So this is something called
the Gilbert-Varshamov bound.
It is attained by a
random linear code.
Looks something like this.
Right.
So basically, as the distance,
the relative distance
goes from zero to a half.
So for binary codes,
the best distance
you can really hope
for is like a half.
So by binary codes, I just mean
that the alphabet is zero, 1.
Yeah.
So as we go from zero
to a half, the best--
or the best rate we know how to
get decreases something like 1
minus the binary
entropy of delta.
This is not that curve.
This is a curve that
I drew in PowerPoint.
But the way to think
about it, at least,
down in this parameter regime
is that if you back off
from this point by a half--
sorry.
If you back off from a
half by a little bit,
let's say, by epsilon, then
if you take a Taylor expansion
of this, you can see that
the rate that you should get
is something on the
order of epsilon squared.
So close to this point, this is
roughly looks like a problem.
OK.
So-- right.
At least this one I
have an answer for.
What's the best
trade-off we know exists?
It's this
Gilbert-Varshamov bound.
Can we do better?
Open question.
However, we can ask--
OK.
So we know that
these codes exist.
Can we construct them, right?
This is also largely
a big open question.
So there's been really
exciting progress
on this in the past 5, 10 years.
So for example,
Ta-Shma's code, which
were a big breakthrough
in 2015-2016 and related
constructions,
these can get rate
very close to the
Gilbert-Varshamov bound
in this parameter regime where
we're real close to a hack.
So we now do have explicit
constructions of codes there.
But in other parameter
regimes, a big open question.
And you might ask, OK,
how about algorithms
for those explicit codes?
So we-- actually, we
do have algorithms
for Ta-Shma codes near
linear time algorithms,
which are very exciting.
So for example, these works by
Jeronimo, Srivastava, Tulsani,
and also Blanc and Doron for
related code construction,
these are near linear--
yeah, near linear
algorithms for these codes.
But again-- for
these explicit codes,
but again, that's sort of only
in this very low rate parameter
regime.
So there's tons of
open questions here.
What is the right answer,
and how do we get it?
These very, very
general questions.
So there's huge challenges
there with binary codes.
OK.
So with that backdrop,
let me tell you
how we can get close to binary.
Cool.
OK.
So the plan for alphabet
reduction techniques
is, first, I'll talk
about code concatenation,
and then I'll talk
very, very, very quickly
about algebraic geometry codes.
And then we'll see an aside,
which this is probably
where the talk is going to end.
What is all this get us?
I'm throwing these
techniques at you,
what happens when you actually
use them all together?
What can you get, and
what can't you get?
And that's what I'll do.
OK.
But first, let's see this
technique code concatenation.
So this is the first
thing you would
try to do when you have a
code over a big alphabet
and you want it to be
over a small alphabet.
Basically, you take
your code word,
so it has all of these symbols
that live in a big alphabet.
And basically, what
I'm going to do is,
I'm going to treat each
symbol as a little message.
And I'm going to encode it
with a little binary code.
So let's say that C prime
is some little binary code.
I'm going to take C1, the first
symbol here of my code word,
and encode that
with my code C prime
to get a little binary vector.
And I'll do that
for all of them.
And then I'm going to get a
final code word that is binary.
It lives in zero 1
to the something.
Make sense?
Cool.
OK.
So algorithmically,
this seems great, right,
in terms of decoding
algorithms, right?
Even if I don't have any
explicit constructions, or even
any good algorithms
in the parameters
that I want for these
binary code C prime.
If they're small
enough, then brute force
counts as efficient, right.
So, OK.
I see some people
being theorists.
Yes, I know.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh, good, even to a theorist
open problem make that better.
Yeah, OK.
Good.
Yeah.
But combinatorially, it's not
so great even for a theorist,
right?
Because the final-- so when you
concatenate, what happens is,
basically, you
multiply the two rates
and you multiply
the two distances.
So even if-- what that
means is that even
if your original codes, both the
outer code and the inner code
that you start
with, are optimal,
their composition
is not going to be--
or the concatenation
is not going to be.
So we won't be able to handle
the right amount of worst case
errors if we wanted to do this.
So side note, actually,
this can optimally,
for some flavors of theorists,
handle random errors
for concatenated codes.
That's a different talk.
But for worst case
errors, this is not great.
So instead, what I
want to talk about
is a technique due to Thommesen.
And the basic idea
here, and this
is maybe close to the question
you were asking about,
is what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to choose different inner
codes for each position.
I'm going to choose
them randomly.
So just random linear codes iid.
So I'll start out with
my outer code word here.
And I'm going to concatenate it.
The first symbol is going to be
encoded by a random linear code
C1 prime.
The second symbol is
going to be encoded
with the random linear
code C2 prime, and so on.
So this is a randomized
construction,
but Thommesen, in
the '80s, showed
that this actually approaches
the Gilbert-Varshamov bound.
So this attains-- we don't
know if it's optimal,
but the best
trade-off we know how
to attain for binary codes
between rate and distance.
That's pretty cool.
And moreover, the thing
I want to talk about now
is, actually, if the outer
code is list-recoverable,
which we just defined and
also is in the right parameter
regime, then not only does
this have optimal trade-offs,
but there are efficient
algorithms to decode it
to half the distance.
So we said that we didn't--
even though it's a
really hard problem
to come up with explicit
constructions of these codes,
with or without efficient
algorithms, actually,
there are randomized
constructions
of these codes that do
have efficient algorithms.
STUDENT: What is the outer code
for Thommesen's construction
approaches?
PROFESSOR: Any MDS code.
STUDENT: Yes, Reed-Solomon
code, for example.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
All it needs is--
Yeah, any of these.
Other-- yeah.
STUDENT: Could you
give me intuition
for why in this case with
the randomized construction,
we don't end up
losing on the rate,
like why the optimality
play out and get--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the rates do multiply,
that's still true.
With distance, I
guess the reason
you multiply the distance
in the other thing, like,
you're in the analysis
and the other thing
is that it's sort of a very
worst case type of notion.
The thing that can go wrong
is that if the adversary
chooses to clobber
each of the symbols
just enough to make them--
yeah, like, she chooses to
concentrate their errors
just right, and it
can throw things off.
Sorry, I'm not
being very precise.
But, yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
Yeah.
And then somehow
this gets around it.
This gets around that.
STUDENT: And so is the idea
that the adversary doesn't
know your randomization, doesn't
know your random coins, or--
PROFESSOR: No, the adversary
does know the random coins.
This is still a
worst case statement.
Yeah.
We can take this
discussion off line.
I don't have--
I have very technical
intuition, which
won't make sense when
it comes out of my face
without a whiteboard marker.
Yeah.
Does anyone have
good short intuition?
Like the analysis works
and then it doesn't?
Yeah, yeah, both of these
are not too hard to show,
so I can maybe walk
you through it later.
Yeah.
Cool.
OK.
Yeah.
But what I'd like to do
now is give some intuition
about why this is the case,
because this should motivate--
lots of people were
asking when I was like,
look, we get these really high
rate codes with fast algorithms
over enormous alphabets
that are list-recoverable.
Why do we care?
This is why-- this is one
reason why we might care.
So let me say how you do this.
So suppose that-- so let's take
for granted this result that
these things approach the
Gilbert-Varshamov bound,
and let's say that T--
the errors are as close
to N times delta over 2.
So we have close to
half the distance,
and we want to correct it.
All right.
So what does that look like?
So here's our concatenated code.
And in our picture, we're going
to have our geometry picture
over here that we keep
having if we want.
And then a bunch of
errors get introduced,
and they get introduced
however the adversary
wants to introduce them.
So maybe this whole symbol
gets clobbered or something
like that.
And here what that
looks like is this.
So we know that the
code combinatorially
is uniquely decodable for
this fraction of errors.
So we know that there
is a unique code
word that is T close to it.
And we just want to find it.
So what are we going to do?
Here's the algorithm.
And I don't have a
citation on this slide?
I think this is first
due to an Indic idea,
and then has been
built on since.
The basic idea is,
let's list a code,
each inner code by brute force.
Again, because they are so
short and I'm a theorist.
I'm going to call
this efficient.
And now, what I'm
going to get is
a set of possible symbols for
each one of these outer code
symbols here, right.
And again, to
Lolita's point, I'm
just being sloppy by
drawing these as distinct.
They could be arbitrary
with whatever we have.
Cool.
And then this is--
now, we can use our
list-recovery algorithm
for the outer coat.
I have a short list of
possibilities for each symbol.
And I have this, supposedly
now, this outer code
that is list-recoverable.
So let's do that.
And now I get a short list
of possible code words.
So in this picture, maybe that
short list looks like this.
But combinatorially, we know
that only one of them is close.
And if I have a short list,
even a polynomial sized list,
that still gives me an
efficient algorithm, right?
I take this short list,
I check everything in it,
I pick the one
correct answer, right?
So by tumescence
result, at most,
one of these things
in this list is
close to the receive word,
just try them all and find it.
And that gives us an
efficient algorithm
to uniquely decode
this concatenated code,
as long as I have an efficient
algorithm to list decode,
or list recover the outer code.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
OK.
So punch line from
code concatenation
here is that even
though it's open,
it's a big open
problem to construct
explicit codes of rate,
maybe bounded away
from zero that
approach the GV bound.
We can get randomized
constructions of these codes
and decode them efficiently.
And if you're interested
in parameters,
hold on for just a
few slides and I'll
get back to that in a second.
OK.
So how long do I have?
10, 15 minutes?
Yeah.
OK, cool.
So let me very quickly say one
other technique for alphabet
reduction, and that's using
algebraic geometry codes.
So as a motivating
question, we might ask, OK,
why do Reed-Solomon codes
have such big alphabets?
Well, it's because we needed
lots of different evaluation
points, right?
If I have just one
evaluation point
and I evaluate my polynomial
at all of those points,
this does not give me a very
interesting code, right?
This is just the
repetition code.
So we need distinct
evaluation points.
And so we ask ourselves,
well, is there
some way we can
get more evaluation
points without making
the field size larger?
This is very basic
idea of codes.
Huge disclaimer, I am
so far from an expert
in algebraic geometry codes.
There are much-- people who
have much more expertise
in this room.
But here's my real
quick picture.
So take some nice
algebraic curve,
call it curly X.
This is my picture
of a nice algebraic curve
as rendered in PowerPoint.
Let's look at all of
the points on curly X
that lie in the
line FQ at the end.
And the hope is so many
points, way more than Q points,
if our curve is nice and curvy,
got lots of points on it.
Then we're going to take
our set of functions curly F
to be some analog of low degree
polynomials on that curve.
So I think, formally,
you pick a bunch
of functions in some
Riemann-Roch space,
and then we're going to define
our evaluation code as usual.
So take all of
our functions that
live in curly F evaluated
all on these points in P.
And now, hooray, we can take
the field size to be smaller
because we got all of
these points for free
because we use this cool curve.
So punch lines are that you
can get Reed-Solomon like codes
over constant size
alphabets that are still
amenable to this basic paradigm
that we saw in the first talk,
interpolate some
polynomial constants.
And, in fact, you
can even get codes
over constant size
alphabets that
actually beat the GV bound.
You just can't get binary codes.
But there are codes
over, let's say, F 49
but you need the GV bound.
Cool.
OK.
That's all I'm going
to say about algebraic.
How many codes, ask
a mathematician.
So I'll tell you more.
Great.
But what I wanted to
do to wrap up the talk
is talk about what do all
of these techniques get us?
So I've given you a
bunch of different--
or I've told you about a
bunch of different techniques
that we can try to use
on top of this framework
of interpolated polynomial
and find some roots.
What happens when we do it?
OK.
So here's just one example.
So these techniques have been
used in lots and lots of papers
altogether, but I'm just
going to pick one example.
This is a paper by Brett
Hemenway, Noga Ramzi,
and myself from five
years ago, or something.
And this uses, literally,
all of the techniques
we've seen so far on
top of each other, which
is why I picked this one.
OK.
And so here's, basically,
what this paper does.
You start with an
algebraic geometry
code that is list-recoverable.
So here's technique
3B that we just talked
about algebraic geometry codes.
So we used one that's due
to Guruswamy and Xing.
And then we used this basic
interpolated polynomial
and find the roots
paradigm to come up
with a list-recovery algorithm.
OK.
We have this, but it's
slow, the algorithm is slow.
So what do we do?
We use technique one, locality.
We take a big tensor
product, tensor it up.
And what we end up with
is a high rate code
with fast list-recovery, but
really terrible distance.
So it can't handle very
many errors at all.
OK.
What do we do next?
We do this AEL
distance amplification,
and that's going to give us
an optimally list decodable
code with fast algorithms
over a real big alphabet using
that technique that we saw.
And then we can concatenate
and do this tumescent technique
that we just saw,
and that's going
to give us a randomized
construction of codes
approaching the GV bound
with fast algorithms.
You can do that all together.
And quantitatively, the punch
lines that you get are--
so if we're interested
in list decodable
or list-recoverable codes,
that's this box here.
We can get list decodable
codes with any rate R
that you want, radius
approaching optimal.
So N times 1 minus R, if you
remember from the first talk
this is what we wanted.
Alphabet size, very close to
linear in N. Decoding time,
very close to linear in N.
And list size sublinear in N.
The punchlines-- and if you
care about binary codes, what
you can get is any rate.
OK, it can't be too big, but
at least it's-- can be as big
as a constant, so
anything less than 0.02,
and distance delta
with approaching
the Gilbert-Varshamov bound.
So the rate is approximately
1 minus the binary entropy
of delta.
And it has unique
decoding algorithms
up to half the distance running
in time near linear N to the 1.
So these are all
the punch lines.
If I describe it like this,
it's like, well, everything
is solved, isn't it?
But these are very rose-tinted
glasses punch lines.
So what I want to
do in the next slide
is maybe take some of
the rose tinting off
and talk about some open
questions that are left here,
a.k.a., the dirty truth.
And, yeah, so the dirty truth
is that, basically, each time we
apply one of these
techniques, they're
very cool and very powerful.
But every time we
apply one of them,
the dependence on
some other parameter
that we don't like to talk
about typically gets worse.
So for example, for all of those
glowing punch lines that I said
on the previous slide, don't
ask me what the constants are,
don't ask me how
big N needs to be,
and please don't ask
me what the dependence
on the gap to capacity is.
So if the rate is
going to be epsilon off
from the
Gilbert-Varshamov bound,
what's the dependence
on epsilon?
OK.
So you can ask me, I will
tell you, it's in the paper,
we worked it out.
But it's embarrassing, right?
And so I think--
and I think that
the reason that I
don't want to answer these
questions in public is,
the reason is because
I'm a classy person.
But the technical reason is
because, yeah, basically,
every time we apply one
of these techniques,
something gets shot up some
exponential power, basically.
And, yeah, so the big
open question here,
a big open direction that
I really want to highlight
is that these
techniques are great,
and they've gotten
us really far.
But I think we
need something new.
So either a new way to
combine these techniques,
or different techniques in
order to make these algorithms
actually practical, right?
Those punch lines that I said
on the previous slide sound
like they should
be super practical,
but no one is going to use
this result in practice
for very good reasons.
And, yeah, I think that
new techniques are needed.
Yeah.
So this is something I
really want to highlight.
Great.
OK.
So I have five minutes?
STUDENT: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
OK.
So maybe I do even have
time for my Technique 4.
Yeah.
So those are Techniques 1,
2, and 3 can be very useful,
but I think there's
a lot of work
to be done to make these
applicable in actually
practical settings.
I want to talk a little
bit about Technique 4,
which I think is maybe more
in the direction of that.
And this is exploiting
structure that's
maybe already present in
the codes or the algorithms
that we have so
that we don't have
to apply these techniques
on top necessarily.
And I have five minutes.
So what's the best
way to do this?
Yeah.
So maybe I'll just
give the intuition.
So, like, let's
recall from Talk 1--
so this is the bit that
I rushed at the end
because I really
wanted to highlight it,
so it's good that I'm getting
to this bit because I did that.
The Guruswamy-Lang decoder
that we talked about,
the only thing I
told you about it
is that it outputs a subspace.
It outputs a constant
dimensional subspace that's
guaranteed to contain a list.
And it turns out other decoders,
as well, also output similarly
structured lists.
So things that live
in this interpolating
polynomial and find
the root paradigm,
a lot of times they output
some nice structures.
And so let's let curly L be the
list that we want to return.
So it's all of the
code words that
are close to our
received word here.
So if we know that our thing--
that our algorithm
outputs a subspace,
well, that tells
us that curly L is
contained in some low
dimensional subspace.
So maybe the picture
looks more like this.
Like here are all my code words.
Here's this low
dimensional subspace that's
guaranteed to contain the list.
But what if my code avoids
such structure, right?
Then I know that actually
the list is smaller
than I thought it was.
It's not going to be
this whole subspace,
it's just where the subspace
intersects the code, right?
So that means that the list is
smaller than we thought it was.
And this leads us to a
few different avenues
to try to exploit this.
So the first is that we
can try to modify the code,
maybe intersect it with
some subspace basis sent,
something that avoids subspaces.
Or take advantage of some
other more precise structure
that the decoder gives us.
And there are lots of
works that have done that
to very good effect.
And then there's another
version which is--
actually, we can
assert that the codes
that we are interested
in themselves
already had that structure.
We don't even need to
do anything to them.
And I find this very
promising because I
said every time we do one
of these cool techniques,
things get--
something else gets
swept under the rug.
And so with this
type of approach,
we don't need to
do that for today.
So here's an example
of how that would work.
Suppose that C is a linear
code with good distance.
And suppose that curly L is this
list that we want to return.
And suppose that we know that
the list is contained in some,
let's say, constant
dimensional subspace.
Then I claim that automatically,
just from the distance of C,
curly L is going to be smaller--
it's going to be much smaller
than that low dimensional
subspace.
Even if curly C
is a linear code,
it definitely doesn't
avoid subspaces.
It is a subspace.
But it will still--
the list will still
be much smaller
than all of the subspace.
So why is this true?
So here's the basic
idea, and this
is from a joint work with
Kopparty, Ron-Zewi and Saraf
from a few years back.
So suppose that here is
this received code word
G. I want to find
all of the code words
that are close to-- or sorry,
not code word-- received word
G. I want to find all the code
words that are close to G.
So what I'm going
to do first is,
let's choose a constant
number of random coordinates
and just assume that
they're correct.
So I'll pick a bunch
of random coordinates
and be like those are right.
I say so, right?
And I claim that when I
do that that for any C,
for any code word C in the list,
there is a decent probability
you might be small, but
bounded away from zero,
that C is the only
thing in my subspace W
that agrees with this advice.
So why is that the case?
So that this has two components.
First, that C does
agree with this advice.
Why is that true?
So C is likely to
agree with the advice
just because it's in the list.
That means it's close
to G. So it doesn't
differ on too many places.
So if I pick a constant
number of places,
there's some decent
probability I won't
hit any of the differences.
So C is likely to agree
in these positions with G.
And then I also need
to show that nothing
else in the subspace
is likely to agree.
And intuitively, the
reason this is true
is, OK, so I have some very
low dimensional subspace,
some constant
dimensional subspace,
and it's a constant
dimensional subspace
of a code with good distance.
So that means that all of the
code words in that subspace
are really far from each other.
And you can use that to show
that, basically, every time you
grab a random position
here and fix it,
you're basically cutting down
the dimension of your solution
space by 1.
You can check with
high probability,
this is going to knock down
the dimension of your solution
space because the distance.
And so what that
means is that you
have a constant dimensional
space to start with.
If you knock it down a
constant number of times,
you won't have any
degrees of freedom left.
So c will be the unique
thing in that list.
OK, great.
So if you believe
that, then, all right,
what's the size of the list?
Well, for anything
in the list, if I
have this same algorithm that
returns it with probability P,
so if you just do linearity
of expectation and stare
at it for a bit, you'll
see that that implies
that the size of the
list is no more than 1
over P, which it actually
turns out with these parameters
it's going to be much, much
smaller than the size of W
itself.
So you can use this for any
code with good distance.
If the code has a little
bit more structure,
you can actually do
something even better.
So what you get
out is that folded
Reed-Solomon codes
themselves, also univariate
multiplicity codes which
I haven't talked about
but which we'll talk about in
his talk tomorrow, I think.
Folded Reed-Solomon
codes themselves
with none of these fancy
techniques themselves
are already list decodable
with rate R radius optimal,
and list size smaller
than it was before.
Although, the algorithms
are still no faster.
Follow up work by Kopparty,
Resch, Ron-Zewi, Saraf
and Silas derandomized
this decoder, the decoder
I described as
randomized algorithm,
take a bunch of random advice.
They showed how to
derandomize this.
And actually, a very
recent work by Tamo,
this is like barely a month
old, has a simplified proof
and better bounds.
This is really pretty--
I'm still processing this paper.
But I think it is still open,
what is the correct list
size for both of these.
So if you're looking
for a problem.
Cool.
OK.
So I should probably stop.
Yeah, all right.
So let me wrap up real quick.
Cool.
So what have we seen?
We've seen a bunch of
techniques to improve
this basic paradigm of
interpolated polynomial
and find some roots.
So Technique 1 is locality.
Technique 2 is
distance amplification.
Technique 3 is reduce
the alphabet size.
And we saw that you can
apply all of these things
all together to get very
good results on paper,
but there's a lot
of open questions
when it comes to making
these actually practical.
And then Technique 4 is, we
can also additionally exploit
some structure in the
codes or the algorithm.
And yeah-- and I
guess I did this
after because I didn't actually
expect to be able to get to it.
But you can lump this in.
You can do all four
of them together.
You can still get lots of--
all of the things.
Right.
And, of course,
yeah, as I mentioned,
there's still lots left to do.
So those are the
techniques that we saw.
How about the open questions?
So I mentioned a lot of open
questions for binary codes,
right?
So practical near
linear time decoders
for probabilistic constructions
of binary codes near the GV
bound.
And then, of course,
explicit constructions
of binary codes
near the GV bound
is the question in
more parameter regimes
than we currently have them.
And over large alphabets,
again, practical
near linear time, list decoding,
or list recovery algorithms
and various sizes.
And I think if we
could get these,
hopefully, I've
convinced you that if we
can get really practical things,
even if the alphabet size is
huge, then with this sort
of concatenation trait,
we can, perhaps, turn that
into better unique decoding
algorithms for binary codes.
But both might require
new techniques.
So maybe instead of my
little cartoon hammer,
we need maybe a fancier
hammer, or my hope
is that we just need a simpler
tool that we haven't thought
of, like an Ikea Allen
wrench, I'm hoping,
is something we
should be going for.
But who knows?
So hopefully, we'll figure it
out in the coming semester.
OK.
So I'll stop there.
It's time for lunch.
[APPLAUSE]
STUDENT: Thanks for having
tutorial and a good time
for a quick question if
people have any, or have
any questions during the talk.
STUDENT: I just want to confirm
the reason he's answering is
that the article doesn't have--
AG code doesn't have the linear
time sensor to reduce from--
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So the question is like, why
do we need to tensor things up?
Yes, because the
original AG code,
if we want a near
linear time algorithm,
it doesn't have nearly
time algorithms.
But after you tensor it up,
then it becomes [INAUDIBLE]..
STUDENT: Question?
STUDENT: Is there ever a reason
to tensor different codes
together?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: What would be one?
So the question is,
is there ever a reason
to tensor different
codes together.
Yeah.
So like for some--
actually, I think in that
very paper we actually--
I think I was oversimplifying.
I think we do want
different codes.
But like one for
algorithms, sometimes you
want one of the codes to have
some nice algorithmic property,
and the other one to have a
different nice algorithmic
property because then sometimes
the decoding algorithm goes
back and forth and leverages.
So, yeah, there are
reasons that you'd want
to tensor two different things.
I just didn't talk about it.
STUDENT: All right.
Maybe we'll take remaining
questions offline.
Thanks again, Mary.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, and speed talks.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]